Hello listeners. My name is Tenisha Urena and I'm going to have a conversation with Adrian Wagner for
Visible Lives an our history project at the New York Public Library is not one thousand
2014 and this is being recorded at 55 West 13th, ah, Street Manhattan
Manhattan New York. It's a pleasure to meet you, Adrian.
Thank you. It's nice to meet you. Um, okay, so I guess we'll just jump
right into it. Uh,
tell me about where you're from. Uh, I'm from North Carolina in a
I grew up outside of a small town called Hillsborough, North Carolina
which is just as rural as it sounds, um, and
And I grew up across the street from a tobacco field
and, uh, it was kind of just like my
parents, my sister, and myself,
And, uh, you know, we lived pretty
far outside of town, like... it, it took 30 minutes to, uh,
drive in to get groceries or anything. So, I'd say it was like a pretty isolated
upbringing, in a way. I mean I was either,
at least for the first part of my life, I was either at school or with
my parents, you know. Not a lot of time in between.
When did your experiences, uh, with disability start and can you explain what it is?
Sure.
Sure. Uh... so actually it's
I...
I suspect now that it began before this, but,
it just... it started to really affect me when I was 12
years old. Uh, I have a visual impairment
uh, but I- I didn't know that when I was 12
and no one else really did either. I was kind of like,
I was kind of a, like, baseball star
And, My father and I were
going out to play catch in the backyard one day,
And, the weirdest thing happened!
And I thought I was crazy the first few times it happened.
And what that was was--he would throw this baseball
and then it would just disappear. You know, it was, like, I would see it in his hand he would
throw it and then it was gone. And that was troubling for a lot of reasons
reasons. Mostly because I was, being
Being like, hit with this baseball [Tenisha laughs] that was just, like, disappearing
[Tenisha laughs] Um,
so, I- I said to my father, like, "Hey, I can't s- I can't see the ball!" You know?
and he was asking me, like, "What's wrong with you?" Like, "Catch it," you know, "What's going on?"
So, I- I talked to him about this and I talked to my mother about this and they said well, you know maybe you need
glasses, whatever, so they took me to LensCrafters... in the mall...
and, uh, they did various tests like, you know, "Tell me what
this looks like. Alright, tell me now. Tell me now. Tell me now" and... it really didn't
make any difference to me what they did, you know, it all kind of looked... the same.
and... at the end
the... optometrist from LensCrafters told my mother
that I was... that I was doing something like I was, I was trying to
pull some stunt to, like, get out of playing baseball or get out of
doing schoolwork or like there was... something that I was trying to get out of
pretending to not be able to see. And luckily,
my mother,
Being the woman that she is, believed me
enough to not believe the optometrist and take [sic] me to a
specialist... where, um... they found out through
Rigorous testing that I have this form of
macular degeneration known as Stargardt's Disease.
Usually macu--Macular degeneration affects older people. But
Stargardt's Disease is like a younger, um, onset
um, and it's a disease that affects... the...
macula, uh, inside of the retina, which is like
where you process light, um,
Which is why for me, it sort of looks like all the
time like I just looked into really bright light--And if I
look away-or-I mean- if you if you look away after you look into really bright light you know there's like that
big, like, spot there and that's what it looks like me, uh, looks like for me
all the time.
Uh, so, that happened I was
12 and they... they told me and my parents
that
some things were going to change probably but they didn't know when and they didn't know how much
and there wasn't really th- a lot that they could... really do about it.
Um, So they kind of just sent us home wondering. And I
think my sister says it the best when she says, you know, "We all knew that we were supposed to be
sad about something, but we didn't exactly know what it was."
Um, and it didn't really bother me until
um, my--
my... 16th birthday.
My [laughter] and we're going to we're going to get pretty intimate, pretty fast [more laughter].
but, you know, you have to. Um, my sixteenth birthday my father, like, came up
came up stairs while I was sitting in my room and, uh,
he came in and he was- he was, like, crying, you know, and
He- he said, you know, "This car that I, that I
bought... when... uh, you were you were
11" and it was, like, this beautiful car. He said, "This car
that I bought, you know, I bought it... to give to you when you were 16
and I can't give it to you now because you can't drive."
And, uh, that, you know
.
It was weird... for me because I felt like...
I was comforting him more than he was comforting me
and that's sort of the relationship I've always had with my parents, like,
.
in terms of, like, visual
accommodations and... emotional accommodations, like,
...they...
don't... really know what to do... and have never really known what to do.
So, um, as this
thing sort of progressed. I mean, it's been, it's been largely up to me
me to, like, figure out... what... uh
I can do about it. I mean how to do... work.
and, um, it seemed pretty logical that I would become
a musician because I guess that's just like what blind people
do. Um, [chuckle] so, I started doing that
um, and I started doing some sound-
related things... uh, and then...
I don't know... I-
I actually did a lot of things, uh, I don't know how in-depth this
... this interview should go on... I guess it's up to me to
decide that. [Tenisha chuckles] But, I mean, I- I did some
things that, like, I don't think blind people necessarily do traditionally
like, I worked for the Park Service [Okay] uh, for a long time, for 3
years and I- I went out to Texas and did trail construction out there
and went to Colorado and did the same thing there and went to
Vermont and did the same thing there
Um, and I- you know
well that time I... would go back home when I wasn't doing that and I would in two and then I would play
with a band that I was performing with and, um, you know
it's kind of, like, a little pop outfit because we were, like, in high school and [Tenisha chuckles] just thought it was
cool. Um, but then I went to college and that sort
of ended in a friend introduced me to rock climbing and I
kept doing the music but I couldn't read music really well
I- I mean I could but I couldn't, like, sight read and play at the
same time. I would have to read it, memorize it, and then play it back so I couldn't go to music
school. Um, but I did get into college and a friend
showed me, like, rock climbing... and,
you know, you'd be surprised how little rock climbing has to do with seeing
[Tenisha chuckles] You know, it's more about feeling. I mean, the idea of being like 3,000 feet in
the air [You would think] and not, like, not looking
where you are. I mean... uh, some people might
consider that problematic [Tenisha chuckles], you know, but I just never really thought about
that. It just seemed like fun, you know?
So... I started, um, I started acting
while I was in college because it didn't really seem to make a lot of sense to
um, I don't know, to do anything
but that, really. I- to do, like, math or science or anything
um, so I- I started acting and directing
because I found that it was kind of the right
mix of, like, something physical and...
um.... something mental.
And... I, uh,
graduated from college... and...
moved up to D.C. where
.
I started acting... and I quickly found that that was, like,
a pretty difficult thing to do if you- if you can't see because
people will ask you to do so many, like, cold readings and stuff. And you walk in
and they hand you a sheet of paper where the text is too small and you say, like, "I can't read this!" and they say,
"Well, get out!" [chuckles] You know? [Ohh.]
Uh, I mean... it doesn't really matter to them, like, they have a lot of people to choose from [Right.] but,
but -and- and I'm not saying it's, like, a sob story, I'm just saying, like, you gotta, you gotta think about these things
so, it didn't... it didn't really make a lot of sense that
I would keep doing that. Though... I did it for a year and, uh,
I wasn't terrible. You know, I did some plays and I directed a couple
things, um, and
Uh, I don't know in that time I had
written- I had written, recorded, produced, uh, a few
albums, um, and I was working on a movie
with a friend of mine one day and it was sort of like the last thing I had lined
up for the year and I went outside to make a phone call or
something and my phone rang and it was a friend of mine and he said, "Hey man," you know, "I'm working on
this cruise ship workin' in this cruise ship band... and half the band got fired,
look, we need you on Thursday for six months. And... we're going to
Australia and [Tenisha chuckles] you're gonna love it, just, you know, pack up your life and get on this boat
So... I- I thought that sounded like a pretty good idea and the
movie... shoot was ending on Tuesday so I, you know, I had 2 days to get it together
and fly out to Vancouver and meet the ship and... and go to Au- Australia
which I did and that was a total... adventure. We
left, uh, from Vancouver, Canada and went down to Hawaii
and then down to... Tahiti and Bora Bora and
which are, like, all in uh French Polynesia, a place that
I still could not point to
on a map [Tenisha chuckles] and, uh,
.
Yeah... It w- I dunno it was really cool
um, and
went... uh
from- from there over to New Zealand and up to Australia
around Australia and up to South Asia
um, and then I did the cruise ship gig
for... another year... after that.
Until it sort of started to seem like I was hiding... on a cruise
ship, you know. It wasn't really doing anything for my career... and
I didn't really see it... going anywhere long term, you know. You see these guys that were on a cruise
ship like 50-year-old guys, you know, playing, like, the same Billy Joel
song that they've been playing for the last 30 years [Tenisha chuckles] except every time they
play it they play it, like, a little bit worse. [Mm-hmm chuckle] You know, so I
thought that that probably wasn't for me.
And I... came back and I
I thought, well,
you know, "What the fuck do I do now?" [Tenisha chuckles] um, and I was in
North Carolina and, uh, the good thing was that I- I had a lot of money
because I had just spent all this time on a cruise ship and there's no expenses at all
like, you live there for free for free... you eat for free...
you, I- I mean pretty much all expenses paid. The flight over there is free
The flight back is free... [Tenisha:Nice.] It's pretty cool, um, so...
I had that, you know, and that was that was a luxury that, um,
made... my move to New York possible.
Um, I had always wanted to live in New York.
but... I... also was like, afraid of living in
New York because there's such a stigma around it. You know, people
say, like uh, "New York, it's a hard town!" you know they, they - and all [Tenisha chuckles] this stuff. Th-There's
that saying like... uh, "Live in New York but not so long that it
makes you, makes you hard, like, "Live in California but not so long
that it makes you soft." Um, and...
that... I don't know. It's- it's so
weird. I- I think New York is, like, the most narcissistic city... in the
world. Like. It's- It's the media capital
or the self-proclaimed media capital of the world. They, like, put out all this media
about New York, it's like, "New York this. New York this." Like, everybody needs to know
about New York but when you come here, like, in a lot of ways
it's not really that different from, like, a small town
um, in North Carolina, like, it's just...
150 small towns all, like, bunched together
but really, like, I think that all of the same things happen
but, um, but that being said, like, it does take some getting used to
obviously and I got here.
And I, um, found an apartment, you know, I did the, like,
bring- or- move to New York with a backpack and look
around for an apartment and find one that night [Oh wow]
[Tenisha: Oh wow.] kinda deal. Um, yeah, so, I found one out in Ridgewood, um,
Queens, which is like, it's fine looking back
Um, there was, like, I don't know... some gang stuff but, like, whatever
there's gang stuff everywhere, um. So I
moved in with this, uh, Australian guy... kind of ironically, you know, since I'd
just, like, gotten back from there. [Tenisha chuckles] And, uh, the next day I was like,
"Alright, I'm feelin' good. Got an apartment. Now I need a job."
Um, so, "What do I do?" And I sort of like... walked out the door with the same
sort of mentality like I'd gotten my apartment with, you know, like "Gotta come back
ton-... home tonight.... employed. Like, I have to work somewhere
sort of walked around and I was looking at, like, hot dog stands
like, "Man, I could work at a hot dog stand!" [Tenisha chuckles] "...or, oh, there's a CVS!"
...or, "There's , there's a restaurant! I could be a waiter!" You know and then I
was thinking about it and was like, "No... I couldn't really be a waiter. No, I don't really wanna work at
a hot dog stand. No, I... I can't use a cash
register... is, is one of my biggest problems and I'm sort of just, like, walking
through the city and narrowing down, like, what I can and can't do
Something I probably should have done like years before that.
and... eventually day turns to night and I end
up at this bar in Bushwick called Goodbye Blue Monday's.
which is, like, a old, kind of like punk bar, I guess, when they were
They were having this open mic night and it was the most godawful thing I'd ever seen
[Tenisha laughs] in my entire life. Like, these, these co- players were like... so
bad. I mean it's a-like an intentional freak show, if you ever go there and if it's still open, if they haven't
like, shut it down for like gross [Tenisha chuckles] misconduct
of, uh, like violation of health code [Tenisha laughs]
or whatever... Um, but it's k-, you know, it's kind of an interesting place
Anyway, so I'm sitting there at the bar... um, watching
these, uh, performers
and I start talking to this guy next to me who, wh-, who doesn't
really seem like he fits into, like, the scene. You know, he's not a hipster
he's in his 40s or something.
Actually, he was like totally wasted. Uh, [Tenisha chuckles] and he was
actually kind of annoying in a way but eh, I don't know. We were just talking
and whatever and it was, like, my second night in New York so
I... I was willing to talk to anybody. I mean, I didn't have any friends up here
um, and, we got to talking
about, like, work at some point and I was telling him how
you know, I had sent out of a- a few emails today about, like, looking for work
and walked around and dropped resumes off at a lot of places and I had actually
like, gotten a job working at this Irish pub
but it would, it would have taken me, like, an hour to get there
um, every day, you know, it's like in Park
Slope. Would, uh, I would've had to, like, transfer trains and rely on the
G and all this stuff, like, all the things you're not supposed to do [Tenisha chuckles. "Right."]
Yeah, and uh, he said
"Man, you're lookin' for work? Well I'll tell you what.
I got a job for you... and this is where it is. And
I'll see you... 9 o'clock in the morning," and, uh
then he left. And... he left me with the address.
and he, he-he didn't tell me, you know, what the job was
Um, but I did kind
of figure from like his... demeanor that uh he wasn't really like the
office worker type so I wasn't really, like, worried about, like, wearing a suit or something to
this. And the next day, I, after you know looking up where this
place was I went down and it was this huge house, um, like
just enormous mansion on the corner Bushwick Avenue
you know, and uh and Gates Avenue in, um,
I guess that's like the line between Bed-Stuy and
Bushwick and I guess I, I knocked on the door or rang the doorbell or something and
he came out and he said, "Hey man, how you doin'? Come on in."
and it was a construction site, you know. So, like, this it was apparently it was a
a construction job which, the idea of sort of made me nervous at first
but you know I thought well, "Hell, I'll try anything once and twice if it didn't kill me
the first time." [Tenisha chuckles] Uh, so, he just started handin' me power tools
and tellin' me to take stuff apart and I just never really got around to
telling him that I couldn't see, you know, um... and
honestly it never was an issue, uh, amazingly.
I mean. I think... that was largely because I spent
most of the time doing demolition and it didn't really matter
if I messed it up because that's what I was supposed to do
[Tenisha chuckles] Um, and uh he would
just leave me a set of instructions in the morning like, "Destroy this bathroom
um, "I'll see you in six hours," and it would take
6 hours to destroy the bathroom. Um, so yeah that was
that was a really good gig and uh, I mean, he was paying me, like,
totally under the table
which was good for both of us [Mm-hmm] and he was paying me, like, $175 a day
and sometimes we would work for 8 hours and sometimes we'd only work for 4
hours you know and then he would say, "Alright, I'm tired. Go home," which, you know, I was getting
175 bucks for that. I I felt really good about it. So... that was sort of, like, my
"move to New York and get a job"
story and, like, I don't know that's that's kind of what
also helped finance, like, the rest of the time. I mean eventually
my my life in Ridgewood sort of fell apart. I mean it
was obvious that,
like, I wasn't gonna to do construction work the rest of my life and I wasn't gonna
really be able to, I mean, be a contractor or something which is what
he wanted me to be, I mean. He wanted me to come on as, like, his assistant and learn from him
and and eventually, um, be, like, equal
to him which sounded really cool and I was excited about it and I did learn a lot but
it just wasn't gonna to work out and he was also a terrible alcoholic who would drink on the job and
you know, like, you can't tell somebody you can't direct somebody who's using a
jackhammer [Tenisha chuckles.] while you're, like, drunk [Right.] It's just not, like, good
business practice. [Not at all.] So I I had to quit that
um and about that same time I was starting to think
like I gotta get out of Ridgewood, you know. Like, my my roommate
also terrible alcoholic because he was a bartender
and we had this cat... that wasn't
fixed and it would, like, spray all over the place. It was it was a big mess
like the apartment was really gross even though my room was nice
the rest of the place was... It was a mess. I would wake up and like find people passed
out in the kitchen and stuff. Like that honestly. So
. I had been. Going down to see
. A couple friends and it made in Park Slope Nancy
for my entire life spent a couple
months trying to figure out how to do that.
And it did. Eventually I found like. A
reasonably priced place and Park which is
. Unbelievable I. Think.
Two blocks away from. Park. Right. Off the train.
And. It's on the same block is the train. Runs
good. And then I plan to go to the new school
. And they love him. And now here I am
.
But at the same time. I got
This gig doing like delivering pizza. Because you know I
needed another job after. The whole mishap with
the construction and stuff but I need I needed something so. I got this other
job that is not suitable for a person with a visual impairment
. But. It was kind of an adventure to
. Them because my thinking was well you know it's summer you know I like riding my bike
even though it's dangerous as hell. I'm. Like why not
try that. Turns out. It's an awful job. You know don't. Don't ever do
. That when it rains. And you still have to
deliver but you know a pile of pizza. And you can't see
. It is. Not. Very much.
Fun.
He don't Weirdly it work out. I mean they didn't fire me I quit
. Eventually because I just thought I was going to get hit by cars and I was just trying my
luck. You. Know really really pushing it. In. And I would
do stupid things. In and out of cars. And I
didn't wear a helmet and I didn't have like reflectors on me but I
didn't wear the. Orange yellow jacket. I was really asking for it
you know. But that's sort of how. I feel in general I can
. Consider myself. A
fatalist really and where do you sort of
. Believe in fate which.
Which is why what happens next. Maybe it's interesting.
Maybe it. Is I don't usually I. Would
wear this monocular which is like one side of the
binocular you know to like see the addresses on the doors of the
places I was delivering pizza to. And one day. I
. Rang the doorbell of this place and suffering. Spared. And
. This guy answered the door and said hey you know what's that monocular bad
. And I told him. And he said well you
know that's quite something. Macular degeneration and you're delivering pizzas. You're an idiot
. I mean he was joking. So
. And he said well I know these people at Columbia that you should go
there and check it out they're doing a lot of things for stem cells for stem cell research. For
macular degeneration. And I hadn't really done any research about that because
basically since I was twelve it had been held under a rock trying to pretend that I can see.
But you know it seems like a pretty good idea in that.
That moment. Service delivering pizza with monocular.
To maybe go check out. Something that they're doing at Columbia so he referred me
to some people who never called me back. But interested
. And. I just started doing a lot of research into like what's
going on with clinical trials so on and so forth. And I found
this clinical trial is happening or stem cells you know for starters disease
in Portland Oregon. Through this. This country
. Oxford biomedical. So I called
him up and I said hey you know I'm kind of getting this clinical trial. Do you still need people
. In. Charge. And really the ideal candidate
young and healthy.
So. They. Also ask me
. OK. We need you to come
here. Once a month whatever. We would fly we would pay
four thousand bucks for your trouble and.
It sounds incredible. Me. Right. Yeah
no I mean. I'll definitely sign.
It. And then then they said
OK well you know you have to get some genetic testing done being that this is a genetic disease
. There's that adding. Whatever that process entails and also you parents have to get
genetically tested because this is a genetic disease and this is science and that's just how this
works.
And I said well hold on. The thing is like.
I'm adopted. So you know it's not just
is easy is saying like hey mom hey dad. Right. Can
we get some. Can we get some new blood because I don't know them.
And. I. Had never known them. And. Hadn't really
even cared to think about them. Until now. I
need. Them. So I started
trying to find them. For this. Clinical trial
. And that still sort of where I am
. But I'm getting further
. All the time and closer. It's just a matter of narrowing down
. Men or
narrowing down. Which avenue. To
pursue. Because North Carolina is a closed adoption state
. You have to jump through a lot of hoops.
To. Find. Your. Adoptive parents
. And
.
Now it's sort of interesting. I like the
. Investigatory journalism
. Or investigative journalism aspect. Of it
. Because that's not sort of what I'm interested in doing anyway
. Yes I'm trying to do that
. And
.
Yeah. That's. That's sort of where I am
. I mean. Some days I feel like it's going well. Some days I
feel like it's not going well. Right.
Now I don't know I mean I talk to. My.
Ophthalmologist and things and researchers and stuff all the time and. I'm just trying to like
get the truth see. If this is actually going to
do what I wanted to do. That's actually out there if they're actually like growing retinas in
petri dishes. You know. But. I'm
. Not really sure. You know I can't really get a straight answer from anyone and I
don't. Know how long it's going to be so my dilemma is
. Do I stick my head under a rock for another ten years and just forget about it until
like it comes out. Or do I. Actively try and make it happen
. To. Change my life
. And. I
.
Mean. Those reasons for doing.
Both of those things. Any questions
.
Very interesting thing. I.
Actually want to take you back. He's a musician. What do you play
.
Bass and I play guitar and sing. And.
I. Consider myself to be a singer
. Instrumentalist. Do
.
You think. That he. Thinks That.
When. He
.
Can.
Sound
.
Well that's authenticity for you and
You also mentioned that he traveled traveled a lot. How was that. Like what was that your favorite
. And why
.
I think for South Koreans. It's really beautiful. We went to
Nice.
And we were to go through the front. And. A
couple of other places along the coast. And I
. Was sort of like. I had a big
crush on. The girl in a
cruise ship and and we had this very romantic
day.
In the south of France where we did like. The super cliche things that
.
You really should actually do if you go there like we got the bottle of wine and we
got to like really stinky cheese bread and we like mint.
Way out in like fun. Found this remote spot like on the coast. And
then. We'd also gotten these grapes. And.
It was so interesting I learned I learned something about food and that's first of all that
French food is the shit. Well. But the reason
why.
Is because it's like it's local. And a lot of people
talk about like organic organic organic or organic doesn't mean anything
. You know. Well actually mean something. Is
local. So we're drinking this wine. And we're eating this cheese and we're eating
grapes. And it was here just things. Like the wine
. Tasted the same as the grapes. And the
grapes taste kind of the same as the cheese and you could kind of like
taste. Like common thread between all these things and
we're like. Tasting these things and talking about this and both thinking the same
thing.
And it was this a beautiful sunny day. In the south of France
. And. We just. Didn't have a care in the world
. And it was just really. Lovely
you know and I just think back to that. And. If I could
do that every day for the rest. Of My Life as. Well.
Right. There's a lot more complicated than. Having a bottle of wine
. On a beach in the south of France. It shouldn't be but it
is.
Because it makes me want to have a bottle of wine.
And. I. Swear that I
mean you know too vulgar for these projects. And say Oh
.
OK So you mentioned you were attending school. So what are you doing.
Money you are pursuing.
And media studies there which is actually I met. Alex Kelly.
Who's. Used to this project and. From the media studies
sort of. Journalism.
And.
Sort of podcast. Creation or radio or just audio
. But not really like. Mixing
instruments in music because. They're trying to get away
from it and I'm more interested in. The narrative. Long for. Storytelling
. So that's what I'm doing here. I'm not totally happy with the new school.
Because. I feel like
. It's maybe set up for people who have already
. Been working in that. Their field for like a long
time. I mean maybe they have been working in audio for a long time but. You know you see these people
come in they're like. Producers of T.V. shows and stuff and make
them feel like they're getting more out of it than I am. Like for me I feel like I
still need to go out there and do it
. So yeah. More of a
story.
Is. A new school sucks don't go here. I'm just kidding
. Just make sure you know what you're getting into before you spend ten thousand dollars a
semester.
OK.
You don't have to you know I don't. Think
. So
.
Too. I was your experience with him here and it is going to shows and. Again
. We're going to play it and then. I was like
.
Oh I don't know. I mean I want to stay. In the art world
. Because. People can make. Accommodations
. You know. If you're working
. In an office. And you like
have a low level job. You have to do all the
other. People. Don't. Want to do.
And. That. There's no room for
. Individuality. But. With
. Music and you know in general. They're
. Like. You know. I don't know. I don't know how to
use the c. Word. And the difference of. Can you
do it you know what would you do you do that you know will trade.
So. It wasn't there you know. It's everything is a
workable. I mean on the issue
. You encountered things like this. All the time
. And people just. I think. People know
different. Things. Yeah I mean it's funny to see people that
. Find. Him. But still. You know
trouble. Knowing their way around. Things and you know I think it's
. Not. In. Your
interface and. Even though that is.
Innate. To something
.
And I. Think that might set up.
Out of the. Thank you so much for taking time to actually a story with us
. And we appreciate it. Thank
you.